♪ ♪
>> Neil: CAN SOME OF THE STATE
LOCKDOWN MEASURES GO TOO FAR.
IN A DOZEN CITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WITH A PROTEST, THEY
SAY, YES.
THEY WANT TO GET BACK TO DOING
WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO DO.
BUT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES SAYS THAT SOME GO
TOO FAR, AND HE CAN PICTURE
TAKING LEGAL ACTION AGAINST THEM
IF THEY DON’T CHANGE THEIR WAYS.
WHATEVER THAT MEANS,
ANDY McCARTHY, THE U.S.
ATTORNEY, INTERPRETING WHAT HE
SAID, IT’S RISKY FOR ME.
I’M NO LAWYER, AND YOU ARE A
GREAT ONE, IS HE SAYING THAT IF
GOVERNORS ADD ON OR DO THINGS
THAT GO BEYOND WHAT THEY
ORIGINALLY INTENDED TO, IS HE
FOCUSING ON THOSE?
OR WHAT?
>> NEAL, WHAT HE IS SAYING IS
THAT WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
REGULATES YOUR FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS, WHICH INCLUDE YOUR RIGHT
OF FREE ASSOCIATION, EXERCISE OF
RELIGION, YOUR RIGHT TO WORK IN
MANY WAYS, THEY HAVE TO NARROWLY
TAILOR THEIR RESTRICTIONS SO
THAT IT’S THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
WAY OF BURDENING YOUR
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS.
AND TO THE DEPARTMENT HAS
ALREADY INTERVENED IN THE CASE
OF GREENVILLE, MISSISSIPPI, ON
BEHALF OF RELIGIOUS BELIEVERS
WHO WERE DENIED THE RIGHT TO
COMMUNAL OBSERVANCE OF EASTER.
SO IT’S NOT LIKE THIS IS A
THREAT IN THE AIR, THIS IS
SOMETHING THEY HAVE ALREADY
DONE.
AND I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING HE SAID, NEIL, ESPECIALLY
FOR WHAT YOU HAVE BEEN COVERING
TODAY IS THAT IT IS NOT YOUR
BURDEN AS AN AMERICAN TO SHOW
THAT YOUR JOB IS ESSENTIAL.
IT’S THEIR BURDEN, THAT IS THE
GOVERNMENT’S BURDEN TO SHOW THAT
TO YOUR JOB BE OPERATED SAFELY
BEFORE THEY CAN SHUT IT DOWN.
AND AS WE MOVE TO THIS PHASE 1,
I THINK THAT’S GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT.
>> Neil: A LOT OF THESE
GOVERNORS, NO LESS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
RECOMMENDED THE STAY-AT-HOME
PROVISIONS.
NOT AS ROBUSTLY AS SOME OF THE
GOVERNORS, I GRANT YOU, BUT
ARGUING, IT IS OUR JOB TO KEEP
YOU SAFE AND NOT PUT YOU IN
HARM’S WAY OR RISK YOUR LIFE OR
OTHERS.
SO WHEN THESE PROTESTERS GATHER
IN TIGHT CROWDS AND THE REST,
ARE THEY ACTUALLY DOING A
DISSERVICE TO THEIR VERY
PROTEST?
AND WHAT IS A GOVERNORS
RESPONSIBILITY THERE?
>> THE THING IS, NEIL, THEY HAVE
MULTIPLE RESPONSIBILITIES.
ONE INTEREST THAT THE STATE HAS
IS PUBLIC HEALTH.
THE OTHER INTEREST, THE MAIN
REASON THE STATE WAS CREATED WAS
TO PROTECT TO THE LIBERTIES AND
THE FUNDAMENTAL FREEDOMS OF
AMERICANS.
AND THOSE THINGS CLASH.
I THINK WHAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS SAYING IS THAT AT THE
FIRST PHASE OF A CRISIS, AND
MAKES EVERY BIT OF GOOD SENSE TO
RATCHET UP THE RESTRICTION SO
THAT WE CAN GET OUR ARMS AROUND
WHAT WE ARE DEALING WITH.
BUT YOU CONTINUALLY HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO TAILOR THE
RESTRICTIONS DOWN AS YOU MOVE
FROM PHASE TO PHASE, AND WHAT HE
IS SAYING IS WE ARE NOW MOVING
FROM THE BEND OF THE CURVE PHASE
TO THE REOPENING THE ECONOMY
PHASE.
YOU ARE STILL GOING TO HAVE YOUR
RIGHTS, BUT THE GOVERNMENT HAS
TO TAILOR THEIR RESTRICTIONS
DOWN.
>> Neil: BUT THEY ARE ALSO
RISKING POTENTIAL LIVES OR
SPIKING CASES.
I KNOW THAT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT THE FRAMERS OF THE COUNTRY
WOULD NEVER HAVE ENVISIONED.
I GET THAT, BUT WHERE DO YOU
BALANCE THAT BETWEEN LIFE AND
LIVELIHOOD?
>> YEAH, WHAT HE SAID.
AND I THINK THIS IS RIGHT IS
THAT IT IS THE NATURE OF
EXECUTIVE POWER THAT THEY HAVE A
LOT OF POWER IN ORDER TO
RESTRICT WHERE IT IS NECESSARY
TO RESTRICT ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
HEALTH, BUT IT IS ALSO FLEXIBLE
FEDERAL POWER AND FLEXIBLE
EXECUTIVE POWER BETWEEN THE
STATES AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, AND THE IDEA IS THAT
THERE IS NO MAGIC FORMULA,
BECAUSE THE SITUATION IS
DYNAMIC.
AND A GOOD EXECUTIVE HAS TO
CONTINUALLY REACT TO THE
CHANGING CONDITIONS AND THE
CHANGING GOALS.
IF THEY HAVE TAMPED DOWN.
IF THEY HAVE SPENT THE CURVE AND
WE ARE GOING TO TRY TO REOPEN
THE ECONOMY, THEY HAVE TO
REGULATE WITHOUT BEING AT THE
FRONT OF THEIR MIND.
>> Neil: THAT IMPROVEMENT AND
CURVE, AND PROOF OF THAT.